c'était hier c'était lundi donc peu
avant 13h30
Karen prend son service elle est
infirmière au CHU de Reims elle est dans
les vestiaires en compagnie d'une
secrétaire médicale qui est un peu plus
âgé qu'elle qui a 56 ans les deux femmes
se connaissent bien elles discutent
elles ont file chacune leur blouse
surgit à ce moment-là un individu
qu'elle ne connaisse pas qui est armée
d'un couteau de cuisine de 20 cm et qui
commence par poignarder la secrétaire
médicale puis s'acharner ensuite sur
Karen et il prend la fuite très
rapidement
il y avait beaucoup de monde à l'hôpital
fort heureusement l'alerte est donnée le
service de sécurité interviennent bloque
l'individu la police était déclenchée
elle arrive très vite sur place et
interpelle cet individu qui se prénomme
Franck il y a 59 ans
qui tient et qui est placé en garde à
vue évidemment qui va tenir pendant sa
garde à vue des propos
incohérents confus il reconnaît les
feuilles il reconnaît avoir porté des
coups de couteau
il explique au milieu de de d'une
diatribe incroyable qu'il se vengeait en
réalité d'hospitalisation en psychiatrie
qui s'était mal passé où il avait été
maltraité
et il va donc la garder n'est pas
terminée très probablement être mis en
examen
dans les dans les heures qui viennent
dans la nuit Karen enfin Karen et
secouru bien sûr à l'hôpital elle est
dans un état où on appelle ça le
pronostic vital engagé elle est soignée
par les médecins qui étaient sur place
mais malheureusement ça n'a pas suffi et
elle est décédée donc cette nuit
comment il a pu avoir accès aux
vestiaire parce qu'on dit qu'il était
alors c'est un espèce de un hôpital on
rentre comme on veut dans un hôpital en
général quand on va à l'hôpital c'est
pour se faire soigner c'est pas pour se
faire tuer donc
j'entendais des sur des émissions des
gens dire il faut mettre un portique de
sécurité informatique bon moi je pense
que le problème est ailleurs dans ce
dossier en tout cas on va l'évoquer si
vous voulez bien tout à l'heure mais
en réalité on s'aperçoit quand même que
cet individu était connu des services de
police il n'y a pas de justice mais de
police facile justice aussi pour avoir
en juin 2017
agressé quatre personnels soignants
juin 2017 une infirmière une
aide-soignante un animateur et un chef
de service qu'il a poignardé
il est arrêté pour ses faits il est mis
en examen je pense aller il a fait un
séjour en prison et il est reconnu il
est responsable
ce qui fait qu'on l'a placé sous
curateur
pas grave mais c'est renforcé merci il a
été placé donc sous curateur renforcé
la justice n'a donc pas pu ce faire
puisque il était inaccessible à une
sanction pénale donc on l'a remis au
médecin et le problème c'est qu'il était
en liberté et le comble dans cette
histoire c'est que vendredi prochain là
dans trois jours la chambre de
l'instruction de Reims devait se pencher
sur son cas savoir ce qu'on allait en
faire c'est pour l'expression
il était voilà on se réunit en mai 2023
pour décider des mesures de sécurité à
prendre cinq ans après donc on est à des
faits de juin 2017
juin 2022 on
abandonne les poursuites il y a un
non-lieu donc parce que la justice ne
peut pas le juger on connaît le
maintenant vient ce système et ce n'est
que maintenant donc en mai 2023 qu'on va
se préoccuper de savoir
quelles sont les mesures de sécurité à
prendre et entre temps il a fait ce que
ce que l'on sait c'est incroyable
donc là donc pourquoi il est sorti on
l'a jugé
abolition du discernement on ne le
jugera pas et ce qui est incroyable
c'est que dans ces cas-là en psychiatrie
comme on est débordé on ne met plus les
gens ce qu'on appelle dans des asiles ou
c'était fermé on les met en psychiatrie
ouvertes avec parfois un traitement qui
peut être suivi ou pas des gens qui
viennent le voir comme il y a pas de
moyens ces gens sont des bombes humaine
déséquilibrés dans notre société prête à
tuer un massacrer parce que plus
personne ne les contrôle et ça c'est
absolument ahurissant soit on les juge
ou soit on les enferme ces gens
dangereux on ne peut pas les laisser en
liberté aucune raison
je voulais juste faire c'est pas le jeu
d'instruction qu'il a qui a décidé c'est
le psychiatre
labolition discernement c'est forcément
une expertise psychiatrique ils sont une
grosse responsabilité c'est psychiatres
ces experts et tout ça vous passez votre
temps vous à venir ici c'est pas votre
faute à nous dire oui encore abolition
du discernement psychiatre expertise et
globalement il y a beaucoup d'erreurs il
me semble-t-il non 70 millions il y a de
plus en plus alors je disais quelque
part que depuis le depuis le confinement
depuis le covid les les problèmes
mentaux psychiatriques ont explosé
j'avais un chiffre il y a 1244
personnels de santé qui sont agressés en
1244 c'est énorme et là c'est pas que
des gens qui ont des problèmes
psychiatriques c'est qu'il y a aussi un
problème de violence sur le personnel de
santé et que de plus en plus d'ailleurs
ils en parlent les infirmiers les aides
soignants etc disent aux urgences il y a
tellement de temps d'attentes etc les
gens sont exaspérés et on va qui va
venir plaquer un infirmier contre le mur
qui va voilà il y a un vrai souci
mais justement le le truc c'est on
aurait pu faire quoi
éviter ce drame à partir du moment la
justice toujours oui à partir du moment
où la justice ne peut plus le gérer
c'est à dire le le juger et
accessoirement le condamné pour l'effet
qu'il a commis en 2017 il fallait il
fallait que le le service de psychiatrie
le prennent en charge ou alors il
fallait c'est ce que voulait faire
d'ailleurs la justice à son de
l'instruction mais tardivement en 2023
savoir décider des mesures de sécurité à
prendre c'est il fallait le faire avant
ça prend les mesures de sécurité là on
parle d'installer des portiques dans
tous les hôpitaux etc ça a coûtait des
millions voir des milliards alors qu'il
suffit simplement quand on a un individu
qui est une bombe à retardement il
suffit simplement de de l'enfermer que
ça soit en prison s'il est accessible à
une sanction pénale ou dans un hôtel
psychiatrique si il est entre guillemets
qu'on sait comme fou
ça peut donc Karen elle avait 38 ans
elle était maman de deux enfants a été
poignardée en plein service et décédé
dans la nuit de lundi mardi la
secrétaire médicale à la 57 ans elle est
encore dans un état extrêmement critique
oui alors sa vie ne saurait plus n'est
plus en danger mais son état est
extrêmement critique oui et le problème
là c'est on est touché de plein fouet
non seulement par le drame de
l'infirmière et par la récidive encore
une fois faire la réitération de ses
actes et ça c'est plus possible on ne
peut plus tolérer ça en psychiatrie ou
non mais c'est impossible à chaque fois
le cas avec Michel c'est il avait déjà
fait ça c'est impossible il faut les
enfermer avant les enfermer on disait
c'est inhumain mais vous ne pouvez pas
laisser des gens extrêmement dangereux
avec des couteaux entrer dans des
hôpitaux tuer le personnel de santé on
attaque aussi nos pompiers nos forces de
l'ordre c'est pas possible